بدايتنا اليوم تقنيه فقبل عده اشهر كان
العالم على موعد مع منح جائزه نوبل في
الفيزياء لثلاثه علماء كانوا حققوا جهودا
كبيره في مجال بحث نظريه فيزياء الكم هذه
النظريه التي تعتبر اساسا في عمليه انتاج
الحاسوب الكمي الذي خرج اليوم من
المختبرات ليدخل في عمليه الانتاج
سيكون
على تحديات هائله
الجهاز على تغيير العالم الافضل عبر
مساعدته في تطوير وتحسين العديد من
الافكار والمشاريع على كل حال المزيد حول
هذا السباق العالمي الذي قد يغير العالم
مره اخرى مع هند ابراهيم من واشنطن
تسمعون عن الكمبيوتر الكمي كثيرا في
الاشهر المقبله وهو جهاز خارق اقرب ما
يكون لعصاه سحريه تضع حلولا مثاليه في
اوقات قياسيه لمشاكل معقده مثل التغيرات
المناخيه وتفشي الاوبئه والازمات
الاقتصاديه ومشكلات اخرى تتطلب معالجتها
الكثير من الحظ احيانا وقرونا من الزمن
شركات التكنولوجيا مثل مايكروسوفت واي بي
ام وجوجل تعمل على تطوير كمبيوتر كمي ليحل
محل الكمبيوتر التقليدي الذي يعد محدود
القدرات نظرا لاستخدامه نظام تشفير يعتمد
على الاحاد او الاسفار بينما يعمل
الكمبيوتر الكمي وفق نظام مركب يوظف
الاحاد والاصفار او كليهما معا في ان واحد
ما يمكنه من انجاز حسابات هائله بسرعه
كبيره
عدد لا يحصى من الحلول والاكتشافات يمكن
ان يحققها الكمبيوتر الكمي في المجالات
كافه سواء لتسريع اكتشاف الادويه عن طريق
محاكاه سلوك الجزيئات او الحد من الهدر في
الطاقه الكهربائيه اثناء ايصالها او تقليل
تكاليف الانتاج او تطوير نماذج ماليه
دقيقه تسمح بالتنبؤ باتجاهات السوق
[موسيقى]
خوارزميات الكمبيوتر الكمي تتطلب فهما
عميقا لميكانيكي الكم لكن المعضله ان هذا
المجال العلمي لا يزال فتيا ومؤخرا فقط
بدات بعض الجامعات الامريكيه ومن بينها
جامعات وسكانسون
تقديم دورات وتخصصات في دراسه فيزياء الكم
وظواهرها
تعاني الولايات المتحده من نقص كبير في
المواهب في هذا المجال ومع ذلك يعد
التمويل الحكومي الامريكي لدراسه فيزياء
الكم ضئيلا جدا مقارنه بالصين واوروبا
لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن
على كل ينضم الينا من عمان رائد سمور خبير
امن المعلومات سيد رائد اهلا بك مع نفس
صباح العربيه اليوم نتحدث عن كمبيوتر يقال
انه سيغير العالم يعني انه قادر على حل
خوارزميات حسابيه معقده يستغرق حلها عشرات
الاف السنين في اربع دقائق فقط يعني اليه
عمل هذا الكمبيوتر لو نفهم اكثر معك ما هو
الكمبيوتر الكمي وكيف يفرق عن الكمبيوتر
العادي الذي نستخدمه
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير
سهام
صباح الخير انا اسف
الحقيقه الكمبيوتر كميه تقنيه لم تتحقق
بعد لحد الان هي ما زالت في مجال
المخطوطات في مجال الدراسات في مجال البحث
نعم هناك رصدت ميزانيات ضخمه جدا بهذه
المشاريع الولايات المتحده رصدت سبعه
مليار الصين رصدت 15 مليار يعني ضعف الرقم
وزياده كمان فعمليا هي تعتمد على الفيزياء
الكميه تعتمد على
بحيث خلينا نختصر الكمبيوتر الكمي يكون
اسرع من الكمبيوتر التقليدي بمئه مليون
مره لكم ان تتخيلوا ذلك هذا الامر يعني
سوف ينقلنا في عالم الكمبيوتر مع الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى عوالم مختلفه تماما انا
اعتقد انه السفر عبر الزمن سوف يكون محققا
من خلال هذه المساله يعتمد اعتماد نعم
يعتمد اعتماد كلي على فيزياء الكم يعتمد
يعني ما دون الذري انت عم تشتغل على اجهزه
لما بتجمع زيرو مع الوان في في عالم
البرمجه معناه انت وصلت الى مراحل متقدمه
مش متقدمه يعني هذا الشيء يعني انت عم هيك
تبهرنا بهالكمبيوتر الكمي فكيف يستطيع
الفرد العادي ان يستفيد من هذا الكمبيوتر
الكمي بحياته اليوميه ولا نتحدث هنا عن
خبير برمجيات وتقني مختص مثلا هل نستفيد
نحن
لا ما هو بالبدايه يعني يمكن بدنا عشر
سنوات حتى يمكن يكون متواجد على مستوى
الافراد لانه من سيقوم على العمل على هذه
الاجهزه هم جيل جديد تماما مدرب على
الفيزياء الكم احنا للاسف بالفيزياء صفر
يعني
مواطنين كمستخدمين في الفيزياء احنا
معناش هذه المعرفه وهذه فبالتالي لا بد من
تدريب اجيال جديده من الروضه على فيزياء
الكم
فعمليا من المبكر جدا اننا نتحدث عن
المواطن العادي والمستخدم العادي لهذه
التقنيات وانما سوف تبقى هذه التقنيات
حكرا على مراكز الابحاث على المراكز
الامنيه على مراكز العسكريه على المراكز
الطبيه نعم صحيح فقط اقول لك انا كنت
متفوقه انا شخصيا في الفيزياء تمام طيب
سيد رائد انا طيب عندما نتحدث عن
الكمبيوتر كم كيف نستفيد منه من الناحيه
او تست
سوف تسهل اعتقد ذلك وما في معلومات يعني
رشحت عن هذه التقنيه بشكل كبير لكن انا
اعتقد انها سوف تسهل بما انها وصلت الى
سرعات المئه مليون مره سرعه الجهاز العادي
اعتقد انها سوف تصل الى معادلات خاصه
لصناعه الادويه في صناعه الباكسينز اللي
هي المضادات
والمطاعيم سوف تصل بنا الى مراحل معقده
بحل مسائل معقده بما يختص في المناخ
وتوقعات التي سوف تحدث على التغير في
المناخ يعني اعتقد انه سوف تشمل مئه مليون
مره على الجهاز العادي سوف تشمل كافه
مناحي حياتنا وبالتالي سوف نكون يعني
ما بعرف يعني الجو بعد عشر سنين ايش اللي
هيكون تفضلي يعني انا تعقيبا على كلام
سهام بتقول لك هي متفوقه بالفيزياء انا زي
ما قلت صفر فيزياء فعشان هيك بدي احاول
استوعب يعني هذا الكمبيوتر ههه هذا
الكمبيوتر بس انا بدي اسالك سؤال
والله انت اللي حكيتها الجمله مش انا طيب
اوكي السؤال
[ضحك]
لا اوكي
ليه اذا انت عم تقول بعد عشر سنين الدنيا
تغيرت والتكنولوجيا والثوره التكنولوجيه
يعني تغيرت اليوم لماذا التركيز على
استخدام وتوظيف كمبيوتر كمي بدل ما مثلا
تصنيع تابلت كمه او هاتف كمي بنفس
المواصفات بحكم انه الجيل الجديد والزمن
تغير من لسا قاعد على الكمبيوتر
والله يا نادين يعني انا بدي اقترح على
جائزه نوبل يمنحوك هذه الجائزه كلهم منحوا
مخترعين
بالفيزياء نعم من الممكن ان تجد ذلك لاحقا
لكن الحقيقه هذه التكنولوجيا اللي هي ما
دون ذري تعتمد على الفيزياء الكميه حقيقه
ومئه مليون مره يعني انا يعني شيء مذهل
جدا بالسرعات شيء مذهل جدا بالبرمجيات هذه
ايش البرمجيه اللي بدك توصل حتى تصل الى
النتائج المبهره في هذه المساله من هون
انا بقول انه سوف نحتاج الى عشر سنوات حتى
نرى اول جهاز كمبيوتر كمي على مستوى
مستخدمين عاديين لانه لا بد من الان بدك
على مستوى الدكتوراه بالفيزياء الكميه على
مستوى دارسي في الفيزياء الكميه مبرمجين
يتعاملوا مع الفيزياء الكميه بشكل صحيح
جدا هذه المساله ليست سهله والله يا نادين
ويا سهام الموضوع خطير وموضوع يعني معقد
لكن مهم جدا وانا اعتقد انه في خدمه
البشريه وسوف يسهل حياتنا وسوف يزيد من
اعداد البطاله تطور الثوري ملفت فعلا من
عمان رايه سموه الخبير ان المعلومات شكرا
جزيلا لك